je te dire quoi faire dépenser en tant
que document sont encore grave tu dois
faire ta peau contre matt hall est entre
nos mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allo mat 1 0 ouais dis moi mon frérot
tu as vu tu nous regardes ou pas 0 c'est
normal c'est cesser 8 maintenant et
ouais on a oublié le dire vacances assez
vite comme quoi tu es devant tu t'es
devant l'écran
avec
un petit concours de danse sur ton type
je pense que tu dois chercher peut-être
détention pour l'exactitude et trouver
ici un moment dans ta tête tu t'es dit
pourquoi pas cyril non bon sens nous ce
casting c'est qu'il s'en sort bien ça
j'ai rêvé salut mon pote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais pas venir c'est la surprise
people ouais elle est bonne tamam well
as l air
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était c'était ça fait cinq ans et
doit partir a surpris je te dire quoi
j'avais pensé en tant que je pense sont
encore grave tu dois faire ta peau
contre matt hall est contre c'est à dire
alors ça part de là tu vois sa part de
like hell s comme je me serais d'accord
comme ceci j'ai vu des gens faire ça non
là je dis non c'est comme souci ça part
de là ici ça commente avenir en tant que
la vérité
wen à grandir encore
[Musique]